R
DISPOSAL TO DEESCALATE THE
SITUATION ON THE GROUND.
>>> IN AFGHANISTAN A BOMBING AT
A MOSQUE NEAR KABUL THAT KILLED
AT LEAST 12 PEOPLE FRIDAY ENDED
WHAT WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE BEEN
THE SECOND DAY OF A THREE-DAY
CEASE-FIRE BETWEEN THE TALIBAN
AND THE AFGHAN GOVERNMENT.
CHARLIE D'AGATA SPENT THE LAST
FEW WEEKS IN AFGHANISTAN AS U.S.
TROOPS BEGAN WITHDRAWING.
BUT TALIBAN VIOLENCE SURGED.
HE SPOKE WITH GENERAL SCOTT
MILLER ABOUT THE SO-CALLED
FOREVER WAR THAT WILL SOON COME
TO AN END FOR AMERICAN AND NATO
FORCES BUT NOT FOR THE AFGHAN
PEOPLE.
HERE IS HIS REPORTER'S NOTEBOOK.
>> Reporter: A CEASE-FIRE OVER
THE MUSLIM HOLIDAY OF EAD
ALLOWED FAMILIES TO BE FAMILIES,
CHILDREN TO BE CHILDREN WITHOUT
RISKING THEIR LIVES.
NOT EVERYONE WAS HONORING IT.
THE BOMBING OF A MOSQUE IN KABUL
DURING FRIDAY PRAYERS KILLED AT
LEAST 12.
IN ALL THE YEARS OF COVERING
THIS CONFLICT, I'VE NEVER KNOWN
SO MANY TO BE SO WORRIED WITH
GOOD REASON.
WITH THE AMERICAN PULL-OUT WELL
UNDER WAY AT BAGRAM AIR BASE,
AFGHAN FORCES MUST STAND ALONE.
THE COMMANDER OF U.S. FORCES,
GENERAL SCOTT MILLER, TOLD US
THE AFGHAN MILITARY HAS TO BE
READY.
>> THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO USE
THE CAPABILITIES THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED WITH THEM OVER YEARS.
>> Reporter: AT ONE OF AMERICA'S
LAST REMAINING OUTPOST, WE
WITNESSED THE MAMMOTH OPERATION
TO EXTRACT TWO DECADES WORTH OF
INFRASTRUCTURE.
A MISSION LED BY COLONEL ERIN
MILLER.
THE TOUGHEST PART OF THE JOB?
ARE THERE MANY TOUGH PARTS?
>> THERE'S QUITE A FEW TOUGH
PARTS.
>> Reporter: A LONG LIST?
>> VERY LONG LIST.
IT'S EASIER WHEN YOU'RE ON A
GREAT TEAM.
>> Reporter: EVERYTHING MUST GO,
FROM HEAVY EQUIPMENT RIGHT DOWN
TO PRINTER CARTRIDGES.
WHY DOES IT ALL GO?
>> SO THE MAJORITY OF THE
EQUIPMENT WILL GO BACK HOME TO
THE STATES.
THE OTHER THINGS WE'RE HANDING
OVER TO OUR PARTNERS.
>> Reporter: THE PENTAGON SAYS
THE U.S. DRAWDOWN IS GOING TO
PLAN AND SHOULD MEET THE
TIMETABLE FOR A FULL PULL-OUT.
BUT AS THEY HEAD FOR THE EXIT,
THE AFGHAN MILITARY FACES A PER
SUPPORT ENEMY.
-- PERSISTENT ENEMY.
THE TALIBAN ARE ON THE ATTACK IN
MULTIPLE OFFENSES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
ALL WHILE TERRORIST ATTACKS IN
THE CITIES CONTINUE.
THE SUICIDE BOMBING ON THE GIRLS
SCHOOL IN KABUL WAS ESPECIALLY
VICIOUS, KILLING DOZENS OF
STUDENTS.
VISITING THE HOSPITAL WAS ONE OF
THE MOST HEARTBREAKING MOMENTS.
MY CAREER.
IF 14-YEAR-OLD MARIAN SURVIVES,
SHE'LL LIVE WITH HORRIFIC
INJURIES FOR THE REST OF HER
LIFE.
13-YEAR-OLD ZEINAB ESTABLISHED
WITH A SHRAPNEL INJURY TO HER
ARM.
"I STARTED RUNNING," SHE TOLD
US.
THE TALIBAN IS SURGING, AND
TERRORIST ATTACKS PERSIST EVEN
WITH SUBSTANTIAL U.S. FIREPOWER
BROUGHT TO BEAR.
WHAT'S TO COME OF THIS COUNTRY
WHEN AMERICAN FORCES PULL OUT
FOR GOOD?
FOR "CBS THIS MORNING SATURDAY,"
CHARLIE D'AGATA, KABUL.
>> YOU THINK OF THE PEOPLE
THERE, OF THE INNOCENT PEOPLE IN
WAR, BUT ALSO ALL THOSE WHO HAVE
SERVED AND THOSE WHO GAVE THEIR
LIVES ALSO IN SERVICE.
>> IT'S A STUNNINGLY BEAUTIFUL
COUNTRY THAT HAS BEEN CAUGHT IN
THIS CYCLE FOR DECADES NOW.
A LOT OF IT FROM OUTSIDE
INFLUENCES.
WE'LL SEE IF SOMETHING CAN TURN
THAT AROUND.
>> THAT IS THE HOPE.
FIRST WITH RUSSIA, NOW THE
UNITED STATES, AND CERTAINLY
IT'S ALL ABO